♪ ♪
>> WE WOULD LIVE WITH RISK EVERY
DAY, WE ASSESS RISK.
WE ASSESS THAT 155 MILLION IS
LOW RISK AND IT IS NOT AFFECTING
OUR PREPAREDNESS WHATSOEVER FOR
DORIAN.
>> I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PROPOSED
TAKING MONEY FROM FEMA FOR WALLS
OR CAGES OR MILITARIZATION OF
THE BORDER.
>> ANY POTENTIAL TRANSFERS WILL
NOT IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO THE STORM OR ANY
OTHER STORMS IN THE MOST OF THE
HURRICANE SEASON.
>> Mike: SOME OF THE
BACK-AND-FORTH AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO TAKE
SOME FEMA DISASTER RELIEF MONEY
AND HELP SECURE THE BORDER WITH
THAT.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
JEFF MASON, WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT FOR WRITERS.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST" AND SUSAN,
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
SUSAN, LET'S START WITH YOU.
BIG DEAL TO SHIFT THIS MONEY?
>> IT'S REALLY A DROP IN THE
BUCKET WHEN IT COMES TO DISASTER
RELIEF FUNDING.
THERE IS SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FUNDS OF THIS IS JUST A
TINY AMOUNT.
FEMA IS ALSO ALREADY ALLOCATED
ITS SUPPLIES TO DISASTER RELIEF
CENTERS FOR THE SEASON, SO ALL
THAT IS ALREADY TAKEN CARE OF.
THIS IS GOING TO -- UNLESS, SAY
THE HURRICANE CURVES IN THEM
BECAUSE OF SOME KIND OF
UNIMAGINABLE CATASTROPHE THAT IS
SO FAR NOT FORECAST, THERE'S
JUST REALLY NO WAY THAT THIS IS
GOING TO IMPACT THEIR OPERATIONS
RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE FOCUS ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE STATE LEVEL.
FREQUENTLY WHEN YOU HAVE
DISASTERS OF THIS NATURE, WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE STATE LEVEL HAS
MORE TO DO WITH THE SUCCESS OF A
GROUP OF PEOPLE MAKING UP WITH
THE STORM.
TO THAT END, FLORIDA REALLY
SHOULD BE COMMENDED -- I KNOW
THEY HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
HANDLING THIS, BUT REPORTS
COMING OUT OF THEIR SHOW SUCH A
GREAT WORK ON COMMUNICATION,
PREPARING, PLANNING, HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL CONTINUE.
>> Mike: IF BY CHANCE THOUGH
RESPONSE IS SLOW, JEFF, THIS
WOULD BE SOMETHING THEY WOULD
POINT AT, THEIR CRITICS AT
LEAST, ABOUT SHIFTING HIS MONEY,
RIGHT?
TO GO SHORT.
SO MUCH OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
WASHINGTON IS ABOUT OPTICS.
THIS IS NOT A GREAT OPTIC, AND
IT'S ONE THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SEIZING ON AND FOR SURE, IF THE
RESPONSE ENDS UP NOT BEING AS
GOOD AS THEY HAVE SAID IT COULD
BE OR WOULD BE AND I IMAGINE THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD FOCUS ON THAT
MORE VARIED >> Mike: TOPIC
NUMBER TWO, A MASS SHOOTING IN
ODESSA, TEXAS, FOR THE WEEKEND.
FULL DISCLOSURE, MY FIRST
REPORTING JOB WAS IN MIDLAND
ODESSA, TEXAS, SO MY HEARTS GO
OUT TO THOSE GOOD FOLKS THERE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I'VE BEEN SPEAKING TO A LOT
OF SENATORS, WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING
TO A LOT OF HOUSE MEMBERS.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS, A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING, SO WE ARE GOING TO
SEE THIS REALLY HASN'T CHANGED
ANYTHING, WE ARE DOING -- WE
WILL SEE HOW IT ALL COMES ABOUT.
>> HAPPY TALK AND THIS PROMISE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING, WE ARE GOING TO LOOK
AT IT, BUT THEY NEVER ACTUALLY
DO IT.
>> Mike: SUSAN, WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING FROM YOUR SOURCES ON THE
HILL IN TERMS OF DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT SOME KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE?
>> THERE IS SOME ENTHUSIASM TO
TRY TO PUT SOMETHING TOGETHER.
YOU HEARD MITCH McCONNELL SAY
EARLIER IN AUGUST THAT WE ARE
GOING TO FOCUS ON SOME KIND OF
BACKGROUND CHECK LEGISLATION,
POTENTIALLY RED FLAG LAWS, SO
ALL EYES REALLY WILL BE ON THE
SENATE BECAUSE IF YOU CAN FIND A
COMPROMISE THERE, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE BIPARTISAN BECAUSE OF
THE FILIBUSTER RULE, THAT MIGHT
LEAD THE WAY IN TERMS OF WHAT
CAN CONGRESS DO.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
COOPERATION, NOT JUST FROM
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE, BUT IN
THE HOUSE WHERE THEY TEND TO BE
MORE PROGRESSIVE AND THEY MAY
PUSH FOR FAR MORE LIBERAL
GUN-CONTROL KIND OF MEASURES
THAN THEY MIGHT WANT TO SEE IN
THE SENATE.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A REAL
UPHILL CLIMB, BUT I THINK THE
ACTION WILL FIRST FOCUS ON THE
SENATE.
>> Mike: ARE THERE SOME
COMMON SENSE THINGS THEY CAN DO?
WHAT ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH ALSO?
VIOLENT VIDEO GAMES, ANYTHING
THAT BOTH SIDES CAN AGREE ON?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS I
THINK WITH THESE IMMEDIATE
REACTIONS TO THESE HORRIBLE
INSTANCES OF MURDER, HIS PEOPLE
JUST TO DO SOMETHING AND THEY
WANT TO DO SOMETHING EVEN IF IT
WOULD DO NOTHING TO PREVENT SUCH
TRAGEDIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, EVEN AS YOU SEE
OTHER ISSUES OF VIOLENCE ON THE
DECLINE OR SERIAL MURDERS UNDER
THE DECLINE, MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
INCREASING AT THE VERY
COMPLICATED THING AS TO WHY.
EVERYTHING FROM YOU KNOW --
EVIDENT FROM THE PRESENCE OF
GUNS TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES TO
EVEN HOW THE MEDIA COVERAGE AND
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
WITHOUT IN ANY WAY RESTRICTING
FIRST AMENDMENT FREEDOMS AT ALL
THE MEDIA NEED TO THINK ABOUT
WHETHER THEIR HELP AND CREATE
SOMETHING OF A SOCIAL CONTAGION
WITH SOME OF THESE THINGS AND
THINK ABOUT HOW TO COVER THEM.
>> Mike: JEFF.
ADMINISTER RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
BELIEVE THEY'RE GOING TO GET
SOMETHING DONE?
>> WELL, THEY SAY THEY DO.
AND THEY ARE WORKING ON
SOMETHING.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT SOMETHING
ENDS UP BEING AS ADVANCED OR AS
STRONG AS A LOT OF PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING FOR IS AN
OPEN QUESTION.
I THINK THE OTHER OPEN QUESTION
IS WHAT ARE THEY ACTUALLY DO ON
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAS WAVERED A
LITTLE BIT ON HOW STRONGLY HE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADVANCED
BROADER BACKGROUND CHECKS
BROUGHT IN BURIED UNDER PRESSURE
FROM THE NRA, BUT THERE ARE
CERTAINLY PRESSURE FROM THE
OTHER SIDE, THE DEMOCRATS AND
PROGRESSIVES, TO DO MORE THERE.
>> Mike: SO HAVE PREPARATIONS
FOR A MASSIVE HURRICANE,
TERRIBLE MASS SHOOTING IN TEXAS
AND THEN YOU GOT NEW MEASURES
GOING INTO PLACE YESTERDAY
RELATED TO CHINA ON TRADE
ISSUES.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS AND I WILL
GET YOU GUYS TO WEIGH IN.
>> WE ARE TALKING TO CHINA, THE
MEETING IS STILL ON, AS YOU KNO
KNOW, IN SEPTEMBER.
THAT HASN'T CHANGED, THEY
HAVEN'T CHANGED AND WE HAVEN'T.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS BUT WE
CAN'T ALLOW CHINA TO RIP US OFF
ANYMORE AS A COUNTRY.
>> Mike: SO WHILE THIS MAY NOT
BE REPUBLICAN ORTHODOXY, THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES WHO SAY WE SHOULD NOT
ALLOW CHINA TO BE RIPPING THE
UNITED STATES OFF.
>> TRUMP IS IN THIS RARE
OCCURRENCE THERE WERE PEOPLE
REALLY DO SUPPORT HIM ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE ON CHINA.
HE'S GOT MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER VERY VOCALLY
SUPPORTING HIM ON THIS ISSUE
SAYING DON'T GIVE UP, DON'T
RELENT, AND PART OF THE REASON
IS THAT CHINA'S UNFAIR TRADE
PRACTICES HAVE LED TO 50 MILLION
A YEAR IN INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
THEFT.
I THINK THE TRADE DEFICIT WAS
SOMEWHERE AROUND 400 BILLION, SO
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM AND IT'S
GETTING WORSE EVERY YEAR, AND
NOW THE PRESIDENT SAYS I'M GOING
TO TACKLE IT AND I'M NOT GOING
TO BACK DOWN.
IT'S CAUSING A LOT OF STRAIN AND
PROBLEMS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT I THINK
ECONOMIST AGREE THAT ULTIMATELY
CHINA IS THE ONE WHO SUFFERS
MOST FROM THIS TRADE WORK.
SO THERE'S THE RUNNING THEORY
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BEND
FIRST, BUT SO FAR THEY ARE NOT.
>> Mike: I THINK A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ON THE BALLOT NEXT
YEAR IN THE PRESIDENT'S ALLIES
ARE WORRIED ABOUT AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
MOLLY, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> THEIR RIGHT TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT ECONOMIC IMPACT.
YOU CONDUCT TRADE WARS LIKE THIS
WHEN YOU ARE IN A HEALTHY
ECONOMIC SITUATION AND SO IT'S
THE RIGHT TIME TO DO IT, BUT IT
DOES COME AT A PRETTY SERIOUS
COST AND CHINA WANTS TO, IT
SEEMS LIKE, WAIT OUT THIS
PRESIDENCY.
I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO START
THINKING THROUGH THOUGH, JUST
HOW DIFFERENT THE SITUATION IS
FROM OTHER SITUATIONS WE PACK.
WHEN WE WERE IN A COLD WAR WITH
THE SOVIET UNION, WE DIDN'T SEE
HIGH LEVELS OF TRADE THERE.
THERE WAS A GENERAL
UNDERSTANDING THAT WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNIST DID NOT MEAN THAT
WE WOULD TRADE WITH THEM.
AS CHINA, WHICH IS A COMMUNIST
COUNTRY CONTROLLED BY THE
COMMUNIST PARTY, THEY RUN THE
MILITARY, THEY RUN THEIR
ECONOMY, THEY MIGHT SEE THAT THE
U.S. AND OTHER COUNTRIES AREN'T
AS INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH
THEM, THAT INDIA, FOR WHATEVER
ELSE IT'S FAULTS ARE, IS A
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY THAT CAN
HANDLE FACTORIES AND YOU MIGHT
SEE SOME KIND OF TRANSITION
HERE.
MIGHT BE A COMPLETE REORDERING
OF THINGS AND THE SEPARATION OF
THESE ECONOMIES.
>> Mike: JEFF, BRIEFLY DO YOU
THINK -- THE SOURCE OF THINK IT
WILL GET A DEAL?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S GOING
TO BE A DEAL ANYTIME SOON FOR MY
SOURCES.
THE BIG QUESTION ON THE SHORT
TERM WHEN WILL THEY HOLD TALKS
AGAIN?
BOTH SIDES OF SAID THEY WANT TO